so it was Heisenberg who had this
enormous Insight right at the very
beginning that
with the
Advent of quantum theory an entirely new
physics has begun a physics in which the
physicist is no longer the onlooker but
he is also if you will in a way to
create the of what he measures
it's a two-way street
and uh
the way us are Addington express it he
says the mathematics isn't there till we
put it there
so it was
first Heisenberg then Eddington soon
thereafter both had the same vision of
physics
and it was completely different from the
classical
In classical physics you postulate that
there is that nature is out there and
you are merely The Spectator of what is
actually out there and when you're
dealing with large ensembles of of the
quantum world this physics works fine
but when you come down to
smaller units it breaks down
and this is where this is
where in a sense the physicist himself
creates what he measures
so does this not apply to regular people
who aren't physicists well we're
discussing physics so what is physics
it's what physicists do
so uh
the the big the big change
from classical to
quantum physics
came about
when
Heisenberg recognized
that
uh
when you are dealing with
what we now call Quantum system
we're dealing with something that we
ourselves having a way created
so this is why
uh
Heisenberg said that
We Now understand that the physicist is
not simply a spectator he is himself
playing he's in in a way creating the
very things that he is then measuring
because there are these two
distinguishable uh
phases of physics there's first of all
the phase where you define a physical
system which you do through corporeal
instruments
and having defined it
you then can measure it
and this is how classical phys how
quantum physics comes about
and the point is that
in In classical
physics the system
gains its reality through first through
being defined by corporeal instruments
it's a corporeal instruments that Define
what the physicist is measuring and then
it is secondly again corporeal
instruments which actually measure
the system that you have saw so to speak
created are our eyes a corporeal
instrument
oh yes of course
I mean I see your eyes I see the color
of the pupil and the so you don't mean
to say you go into the lab and you set
up a laser and then all of a sudden
quantum mechanics is created so is this
an observer the table
well
there are really two tables
the table of quantum physics which is
simply the SX of
of
this X
and then there are the quantum tables so
the SX was the classical
yes that's that's classical so the
difference is that in quantum theory
the physicist not only describes what is
out there
but in a sense it creates what is out
there you just watched a clip from the
theories of everything channel for the
full video and all its magnificence then
click here and if you'd like to see more
then subscribe enjoy